foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP
3755 object class Euclid
special containment procedures
Personnel reading this document are
required to examine the attached
photograph before reading Beyond this
paragraph those unable to immediately
identify the number of objects pictured
as indicated by the caption should close
this file and report to the senior
researcher assigned to
scp-3755 otherwise no special action is
required before reading the rest of this
document
warning the following material contains
class 1 Cognito hazards read the above
portion of the special containment
procedures before proceeding
Foundation staff unable to display
scp-3755-1 or who show symptoms of
scp-3755-2 should be reported to the
senior researcher assigned to
scp-3755 for documentation and treatment
persons showing symptoms of scp-3755 II
are to not be made aware of their
condition clearance level 2 3755 is
required to access this document
Clarence level 2 3755 is not to be given
to Personnel symptomatic of
scp-3755 II information regarding
scp-3755 particularly known
scp-3755 II manifestations is considered
Cognito hazardous to anyone who does not
possess clearance level 2 3755
the number is 755 is on the list of
keywords monitored by Foundation web
crawlers situations where
scp-3755 is suspected to have been
discovered by members of the public are
to be investigated and contained using
procedures standard for outbreaks of
class 1 Cognito hazards with the
additional provision that all members of
the responding mobile task force must
have clearance level 23755
description
scp-37551 is a phenomenon where
individuals presented with 755 similar
items are able to assess the exact
number of items in the set this
enumeration is performed immediately
within less than 100 milliseconds and
has only been observed with sets of 755
objects subjects who display
scp-3755-1 show high confidence in their
assessment and show no surprise when
proven correct even when reminded of the
unlikelihood of perfect estimation with
such a large number of objects MRI scans
comparing brains performing
scp-3755-1 and non-anomalous subitizing
display similar activation patterns
scp-37551 can be displayed by 83 percent
of humans capable of subitizing
scp-3755 II is a psychological condition
found in those unable to display
scp-3755-1 subjects affected by scp-3755
II exhibit hesitance in situations that
require the assignment of numerical
values to physical objects or abstract
Concepts the condition initially
manifests uniquely in each individual
who suffers from scp-3755 II influencing
a single aspect of their daily lives see
document 3755a for examples of known
cases when a person discovers they are
unable to display
scp-3755-1 their
scp-3755-2 symptoms worsen the
development of these symptoms progresses
as follows
Phase One initial state
subjects regularly suffer minor doubt
when recalling numbers counting objects
or estimating amounts in relation to
their
scp-3755 II manifestation these Downs
usually manifest as light urges to
recount or recheck their Source on a
matter
Phase 2 72 hours after exposure to
scp-3755-1
scp-3755-2 symptoms increase in
intensity subjects feel anxiety when
introduced to situations connected to
their manifestation
phase three one week after exposure
subjects cannot perform tasks which
involve their scp-3755 II manifestation
without seeking confirmation on their
assessments this confirmation must come
from another individual
phase four three weeks after exposure
subjects no longer find external
confirmation sufficient to calm their
doubts
phase five one month after exposure
subjects reject all numerical
assessments that relate to the area of
their
scp-3755 II manifestation even when such
assessments originate from outside
sources such as trusted colleagues or
friends progression through these phases
can be more rapid in cases where
subjects have existing anxiety or
compulsive disorders
scp-3755-2 symptoms can be lowered to
phase one levels through the application
of Class B amnestics targeting the
memories of
scp-3755-1 exposure amnestic treatment
has only proven effective before the
onset of phase four
additionally
scp-3755 II manifestations appeared to
be transmittable when the details of
another person's symptoms are brought to
the attention of someone susceptible to
scp-3755 II they begin to display
similar symptoms the reason for this
transmission is unknown ongoing research
focuses on determining if the
transmission Vector is a form of
hypochondria or an anomalous memetic
effect amnestics are ineffective in
purging transmitted symptoms of
scp-3755 II
document
scp-3755 a
scp-3755 II manifestation log
This Record contains a partial list of
members of foundation staff known to
have been affected by
scp-3755 II individual Junior researcher
Henry zoltowski area of
scp-3755-2 manifestation amounts of
coins
common Phase 1 manifestation found
difficulty making exact change
for this stage of progression phase five
manifestation at later stage refuses to
shop at locations which do not accept
credit cards
individual Dr Jules Pendleton
area of scp-3755 II manifestation speed
limits
common phase one manifestation is often
unsure of the speed limit even in areas
she knows well
for this stage of progression phase two
manifestation at later stage requested
to carpool with Dr to and from site 19
since recovered
individual agent Donald rice
area of scp-3755 II manifestation times
of day
common Phase 1 manifestation recheck
schedule in 15-minute intervals to
confirm when regular meetings are to
take place
for this stage of progression phase one
manifestation at later stage
non-applicable
individual Junior researcher Boris
lockhead
area of scp-3755 II manifestation
measurements
common phase one manifestation always
looks up conversion factors for imperial
units
for this stage of progression phase one
manifestation at later stage not
applicable
individual d-33087
area of
scp-37552 manifestation ages
common Phase 1 manifestation habitually
calculates the ages of their children
for this stage of progression phase five
manifestation at later stage birth
records were only found for two of the
four children
d-33087 claimed to have
d-33087 did not accept the veracity of
the documents and stated their oldest
child was 15 years old and their
youngest children supposedly Twins were
turning 40 next October
d-33087 was 34 years old upon reaching
phase five
individual Dr Jason Brave
area of
scp-37552 manifestation medical dosages
common phase one manifestation has
almost handed out improper doses of
amnestics on five occasions in the past
month
for this stage of progression phase two
manifestation at later stage deferred
all requests for prescription
fulfillment to Dr since recovered
individual analyst Ruth ninsular
area of
scp-37552 manifestation food portions
common phase one manifestation over
orders food for office parties
for the stage of progression phase one
manifestation at later stage
non-applicable
individual Dr Victor salvor
area of
scp-37552 manifestation measurements
common phase one manifestation often
inserts the wrong SI prefixes in drafts
for SCP documents for this stage of
progression phase three
manifestation at later stage redacted
since recovered
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
accept
Timothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
vibing Shockwave
killer Hunter Jew
fire of prime
Indie versus the world
Spencer arduin
rubbish bin 69.
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
zazapan
Lemke
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
and oh crop guy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you